well congratulations on season four of
manifest so excited that it's back
uh what was it like getting that
confirmation that you were going to be
able to give manifest fans like actual
closure on the show
exhilarating I mean the fact the idea
that we would have finished it at the
end of season three with everything that
happened with Grace with Cal with Eden
with everything would have been
just the cruelest thing I think we could
have done not only to uh the characters
but uh to our fans
and the first half
are delivered like so many big
Revelations now we know like the death
date is actually tied to the apocalypse
and it's like it's so much bigger now so
do you think that this final half of the
Season still going to be able to focus
in on those like those very intimate
relationships between these characters
that we love while also dealing with
this huge like the world is ending
yeah always always you know I think
that's what we do best on manifest is
that we
um concentrate so much on the uh
the characters the characters
interactions with one another and that's
what's so compelling for us I think is
that we get to play these very real very
emotional very connected uh human scenes
um with all of this huge story that's
happening around them and we will always
always
um in every episode until the very end
concentrate on the characters and their
journey through this this crazy thing
that happened to them I know manifesters
still have like so many questions and
theories and like queries about what's
going to happen in these final episodes
do you think that most if not all of
those questions that are still lingering
those loose threads are all going to get
tied up by the end
yes absolutely great I everything is
going to get tied up and you and all
your questions will be answered
including the biggest question of all
what happened to those passengers on
flight 828 which is definitely the most
pressing pressing question right now
it's like did they die did everybody get
reincarnated like re brought back to
life like so many questions but you
bring a great point because the world
does open up the story does open up it's
not just about those passengers now now
it's affecting everyone in the entire
world so
um the stakes have gotten much bigger
and a much more immediate uh than they
ever before which definitely makes for a
great final season and I think the
villain for this show or the kind of
villa Angelina is still kind of a
sympathetic character because she has
gone through so much trauma and her like
motivations are like righteous
indignation what do you think it is
about her as a villain that makes her so
fascinating because everybody I've
talked to about the show just thinks
she's so fascinating yeah I mean she is
fascinating one I think it's Holly
Taylor is such a brilliant actress and
she brings so much to the role and so
much uh so many layers which
um always always makes for a great
villain you know you know no villain
thinks they're you know no villain is
the villain in their own story and you
know I think she thinks she's doing what
is right and what she feels is right and
that's compelling in itself
um and I think what it does what that
character does in terms of of Ben for
sure is she makes people look at their
own goodness versus their own evilness
and I think
um for Ben for sure as we go through
into the second part you know
for him
to try to understand
what makes Angelina the way that she is
will somehow inform him about his own
goodness and his own redemptedness uh
towards the end and she's an important
character in that way because I think
she makes the rest of the characters
really look at who they are and how
they're living definitely and you know
at this the end of season three
delivered such like heartbreak with what
happened to Grace and I think that was
like the most heartbreaking thing
picking up with season four because you
see Ben have this really complicated
relationship now with Cal because he has
this like guilt and this regret and this
like I don't want to say animosity but
he has like these very complex feelings
Sports and Sun now and I felt like so
much of manifest has been centered
around that father-son Dynamic so I was
curious what it was like for you coming
back and playing a completely different
approach to that father-son Dynamic uh
juicy it was juicy it was so great
um uh playing with Ty and you know we
were so lucky that we we uh got him to
come onto the show and he plays it so
brilliantly
um but it was great it was great to be
able to
um take a dynamic and take a character
and in a way reinvent him uh for the
beginning of season four and because he
is in such a new place and the
characters all of the characters are in
such a new place and that dynamic
between Ben and Cal is super super
complicated now because you know as you
say there's something deep down inside
of bend that blames Cal and uh blames
him for his mother's death because of
his relationship with Angelina which he
doesn't quite understand he doesn't get
he doesn't
um
fully under stand why he would have this
connection with her and I think that
creates you know some really tough
situations between the two of them
because you know he's still a little boy
he he's not a grown-up he's not an adult
and
it's at a time where he needs his dad
the most
and
um Ben knows that but there's a part of
Ben that just he can't give himself over
to him
to be his father which is heartbreaking
and horrible and um and Ben doesn't
understand it either he doesn't
understand why he can't why he can't go
there he just knows that he has these
complicated feelings
so you know the journey between those
two characters you know it evolves and
and evolves even more in part two into
hopefully a really beautiful place and
um
yeah uh it was you know as an actor to
be able to go in and and you know show a
different side to these characters and
how they've evolved to the place that we
find them in was uh just it was a gift
it obviously been still grieving Grace
but I will say one scene that has
definitely I've seen talked about a lot
online is the fake kiss between Ben and
sonavia in episode seven do you think
that Ben will ever be in a place to find
love again and you know if the world
doesn't end
um yeah I think so I think he'll be able
to
find it it may not be in the way that
people think or it may be uh it may be
in a place that people think but I think
there's definitely growth there that
happens you know and I think uh as we go
into part two of season four you will
see
um you know Ben's heart open and
um
and him sort of crawling back to
um
the the bin that we've known from the
beginning although changed for sure from
this experience but um change for the
better I think and yeah I I think it's
heart opens
another really fun part of season four
is you make your directorial debut so
can you talk a little bit about what led
up to that was there like a purpose
behind why you chose that episode I'm
just so curious about the whole process
uh yeah I mean sure absolutely
um I've been wanting to direct for a
long time and I it's been this itch that
I've had and you know Jeff rake and I
had talked about doing an episode in
season three
and uh covet hits we didn't know you
know how we were going to do anything
you know nobody knew what to do in the
world so we thought that probably wasn't
the best time for me to go and uh my
first time doing it uh but thankfully
you know we came back Netflix saved us
and we came back for season four so the
opportunity was there and you know I I
didn't get to choose the episode the
episode was chosen for me just the the
way that um schedules work and and and
and and and different things like that
so it it I luckily this great episode
fell into my lap and I was so excited
that I was able to
um help tell a more 360 degree view of
of the story a story that you know is so
important to me and also I felt that it
was an episode and a story that we don't
get to tell very often on manifest and
it was it was it was taking a character
taking Cal and being able to take him
out of the situation of our mystery of
our drive for just a second and allowing
him to live in the presence and not
think about all of this stuff not think
about mythology not think about Sapphire
not think about the death date not think
about any of this stuff and live for
maybe the first time in his life and
that I just I fell in love with that
idea and I was just so excited about the
script and so excited to be able to
um you know as a direct you know as an
actor our role is very it can be very
singular and but as a director I get to
work with everybody and that was my
favorite part that I was able to uh tell
that story and get to play in the
sandbox with the entire the entire tribe
I just I I loved it and um yeah and and
everybody made me look like I knew what
I was doing it's a very it's a very good
episode you directed it very well was
there anything about directing that
surprised you you know you've acted for
so many years you've seen other
directors work but being in that role
was like oh I didn't even realize this
from like my side of the camera
um yeah it's not that I didn't realize
it but I didn't feel it as much and
that's the pressure of time time is your
enemy on any set no matter how many days
you have to shoot an episode in but the
clock is always ticking and the clock is
your Nemesis so that was the biggest
sort of wake-up call for me that I had
to uh really try to beat that ticking
clock every day and uh you know
preparation Prep Prep that is the clocks
Nemesis so that's what I tried to do I
just prepped my ass off and uh hope for
the best
and of course everybody else picked up
the slack for me did you reach out to
like any previous directors that you had
worked with for like advice or like oh
my my gosh that's absolutely and you
know and all of our directors on
manifest and you know Romeo who is our
uh producing director who I've worked
with many many many many times he did
many episodes of Once Upon a Time as
well we've probably done over 22
Episodes of Television together so he
was really my uh I I you know I I was I
I he called it I was a shadow so I would
always send the messages from his shadow
you know and in questions and he was a
big big help to me and a big inspiration
to me I love that guy to death uh Dean
white who I've also worked with many
many times on Once Upon a Time and
manifest uh he he directed uh 402 of
this season and and many other episodes
for us
um I asked a lot of uh a lot of
questions to him and Mike Smith who
another one of our great manifest
directors so I I wherever ever I could I
asked everybody everybody
in fact I found the most powerful thing
that I could say
um and I think it's probably the most
powerful thing anybody could say in any
kind of situation like that is I don't
know
I don't know so
um that was really useful to me that
definitely is a good a
you know manifest is coming to an end
Marvel's starting to like draw in the
Multiverse and like bring people back
who have been previously in it and I
know Zach Levi's fandral is technically
dead but are you hoping that call might
come someday I would love to go back and
play in that universe
anytime anytime at all uh whether it's
fandral or another character so uh the
the my my phone line is open I will
start the petition for you thank you
well this is great thank you thank you
it's nice to meet you